[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros gracias por estar con
nosotros el problema de nacer niña en la
india ha sido una constante sin embargo
en una sociedad altamente patriarcal hay
una luz al final del túnel la escuela
parda parda de una organización no
gubernamental ofrece a muchas niñas la
esperanza de liberarse y empoderarse
miles de ellas reciben educación
gratuita comida y atención médica este
centro educativo quiere que las mujeres
crezcan con una mentalidad feminista y
que ocupen el lugar que les corresponde
en el futuro del país durante 20 años
las escuelas de esta red sólo han
acogido a niñas es una revolución en
india donde la mayoría de las jóvenes no
tienen derecho a expresarse este sistema
ha sido altamente exitoso debido a que
las alumnas tienen una tasa de
asistencia del 85 por ciento frente al
65 por ciento de las otras escuelas del
estado de uttar pradesh nuestros
reporteros nos adentran en esta escuela
para ver cómo están cambiando la vida de
las jóvenes indias
[Música]
ah
tienen entre 12 y 15 años
[Música]
son colegiadas y todas proceden de la
casta más baja de india los dalits
[Música]
en matemáticas el profesor nos dio unos
ejercicios importantes como si algunos
teoremas ok
- envías por waza está bien y había
tareas de inglés no creo
voy a un colegio que está a 12
kilómetros de mi casa
coge el autobús todos los días para ir
hasta allá
[Música]
me permite compartir con amigos es un
momento para hablar con mis amigas me
gusta mucho ese momento
a sus 16 años canicas es una de las 1600
niñas del estado de uttar pradesh que se
ha matriculado en esta escuela
la escuela apartada verdad
[Música]
un proyecto educativo único en índia la
escuela es gratuita desde el jardín de
infancia hasta el duodécimo grado y cada
alumna recibe material de estudio
uniformes transporte tres comidas al día
e incluso toallas higiénicas porque aquí
todo está pensado para que canicas y sus
amigas florezcan lejos de su destino
prometido por su origen social
vengo de un entorno rural y mi familia
no puede pagar mi educación en mi pueblo
es difícil estudiar porque mucha gente
tiene una mente cerrada y no enviar a
sus hijos a la escuela
quiero ser doctora y sé que aquí puedo
hacer realidad mis sueños
[Aplausos]
en la escuela canicas recibió un curso
sobre igualdad de género
hay que decir que el nivel de
discriminación en india es tal que a
menudo conduce a la violación o al
asesinato
[Música]
saben algo sobre la desigualdad de
género
[Música]
la desigualdad de género significa la
discriminación entre dos géneros
especialmente en nuestra sociedad la
discriminación entre niñas y niños los
chicos pueden estudiar jugar pueden
salir al exterior a estudiar pueden
trabajar pero para las chicas hay mucha
discriminación no pueden salir a
estudiar no pueden ir a la escuela los
hombres piensan que las chicas sólo
están para las tareas del hogar
está muerta
en su curso reina sharma enseña a sus
jóvenes alumnas a salir del determinismo
sexual
y la tarea parece desalentadora en india
sobre todo en el campo nacer niñas se
sigue considerando una maldición desde
andar perdedora en casa a nuestros
padres siempre nos piden que bebamos
menos leche para que nuestro hermano
pueda tener más cosas
si cocinamos algo bueno en casa nuestros
padres también nos piden que comamos
menos y demos más a nuestro hermanito
tutor acá le havre mágico de paypal que
damos a right to
los niños tienen derecho a heredar los
bienes de sus padres las niñas no los
padres siempre dicen no importa lo que
haga es un niño y nunca se meterá en
problemas su futuro está asegurado
porque la propiedad de los padres es su
propiedad
pero el futuro de las niñas no está
asegurado en absoluto
los padres piensan que una chica
encontrar a un chico que se casara y que
por tanto no tendrá preocupaciones
el ejercicio que les propongo ahora se
basa en la desigualdad de género
cuáles son las características
biológicas de la desigualdad y qué
cambios se deben al impacto social
ah
por cada situación que les dé tienen que
decir si es una desigualdad biológica y
permanecer sentadas
si se trata de una desigualdad social se
ponen de pie
[Música]
y más a mano
cuando estudiar
llevar un vestido
más la menstruación
verano
cambiar las mentalidades cambiar la
imagen que las mujeres tienen de sí
mismas
esta es una de las misiones que se ha
propuesto el equipo pedagógico de la
escuela virtual a todos me alegra verlos
a todos reunidos tenemos que tener una
cosa en mente si damos educación en este
instituto tenemos que hacer que los
estudiantes se conviertan en personas
positivas para que sean un modelo para
nuestra sociedad
si le dan 100 rupias a un hombre
imaginen lo que hará cuando el mal se
irá de fiesta y lo gastará en pequeñas
cosas inútiles pero si le das a una
mujer 100 rupias no sólo proporcionará
alimentos a la familia sino que incluso
conseguirá ahorrar dinero si se da a las
mujeres la oportunidad de crecer la
sociedad será mucho mejor no tiene
piernas es haití y por desgracia estamos
en una sociedad en la que hay demasiada
disparidad entre los sexos
tommy hunter de es parte
[Música]
muchas de estas jóvenes adolescentes son
víctimas de acoso y violencia sexual en
el seno de sus propias familias por ello
la escuela ofrece un curso de teatro
sobre este tema
el objetivo es liberar su palabra sobre
un tema tabú aquí una escena entre una
niña y su padrastro
[Música]
padre toma tú te tienes aquí
y deja de agarrarme las manos porque
tienes miedo por favor déjame ir no te
preocupes nadie lo sabrá
soy como tu hija eres mi padrastro
detente vamos nadie lo sabrá
[Música]
parece vida
acoso y violencia sexual en india las
niñas de leeds se enfrentan a grandes
obstáculos para su existencia pero lo
que les impide acceder a la educación
son principalmente los matrimonios
forzados
cuando los padres arreglar el matrimonio
de su hija sin permiso y la chica no
quiere casarse en falta de tener que
pensar entonces nos cuenta su problema
oa veces nos lo cuenta una de sus amigas
así que voy donde la familia para
conocer a sus padres y tratar de
disfrutar de satena tiene un cabrito tim
barbilla en apartadó todavía tengo
aquí las castas rigen la vida de cientos
de millones de personas
a pesar de la edad legal fijada en 18
años el matrimonio de menores persiste
en el campo
[Música]
ese día la directora visito a la familia
de una alumna del último curso que
llevaba varios meses sin acudir a la
escuela
hola cómo estás
la madre de esta joven de 16 años está
gravemente enferma él quiere que su hija
se case lo antes posible
había meses que ya le digo que no
necesita preparar la boda que siga
estudiando le ayudará por la mañana y
por la noche con las tareas domésticas
su hermana pequeña también podrá ayudar
pero nada tenga la educación de su hija
vale no no la detendrá está seguro no
cocina
télam
y mandar la falda
su madre y su padre ya no le permiten ir
a la escuela sin matar a la madre está
enferma y en cama así que su hija tiene
que hacer la limpieza segundo punto su
situación económica es realmente mala
escarrá en que sus hermanos mayores la
instan a casarse pero es demasiado joven
para casarse ahora de la reina y todo es
batimos y estoy muy contenta porque está
de acuerdo conmigo y me ha prometido que
su hija volverá al colegio a partir de
mañana sin regular school life miras a
la nota hago esto para que estas chicas
sean mejores es un sueño para mí
conseguirlo que lidiará en ese acceso
que el orden los que antes eran llamados
intocables sufren así una doble
desventaja
[Música]
la de haber nacido niña y en una casta
inferior nos encontramos con canicas en
el pueblo de bat pura a 12 km de la
escuela
dónde está alta son pequeños
por favor tómalo
corta esto en trozos pequeños
los niños me ayudan a cocinar los
domingos si estuviera sola no tendría
tiempo para hacer todo
con messi
y tengo que trabajar todo el día en casa
a veces incluso dejar llorando a mi bebé
tengo demasiado que hacer
a mi mamá por favor pon este té en una
taza
qué canica reciba educación es un motivo
de orgullo para su madre
mis padres no me permitieron estudiar
así que queremos que nuestra hija tenga
éxito en el futuro
me siento orgullosa porque tengo tres
hijas y ningún hijo
y su padre tiene una afección cardíaca
yo también tengo otras enfermedades si
canicas va bien en la escuela podrá
valerse por sí misma en el futuro y
podrá cuidar de sus hermanas menores nos
pasa algo
y poco más
[Música]
soy realmente un hombre pobre no tengo
mucho dinero afortunadamente no tengo
que pagar la escuela de canicas la
administración de la escuela nos ayuda
mucho gracias a ellos podemos avanzar en
la vida
sin embargo y a pesar de los esfuerzos
sólo el 30 por ciento de las mujeres
indias trabajan hoy en día
además de aprender informática inglés y
matemáticas estas jóvenes estudiantes
aprenden a armarse en una sociedad
estructurada por el patriarcado
para evitar que abandonen la escuela
antes de tiempo la directora les ofrece
10 rupias al día menos de un dólar
además de las tres comidas diarias
gracias a este sistema las alumnas de la
escuela para datar daddy tienen una tasa
de asistencia del 85 por ciento muy
superior a la de las otras escuelas de
uttar pradesh
[Música]
una vez más gracias por estar con
nosotros recuerde que puede ingresar a
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
para ver este y las anteriores emisiones
hasta la próxima semana
[Música]